In order to build
circuits to manipulate,
transmit or store information,
we are going to need some
engineering tools to see
if we're choosing a good
representation for
the information --
that's the subject
of this chapter.
We'll study different ways of
encoding information as bits
and learn the mathematics
that help us determine
if our encoding is a good one.
We'll also look into what we can
do if our representation gets
corrupted by errors.
It would be nice to detect
that something bad has happened
and possibly even
correct the problem.
Let's start by asking
"what is information?"
From our engineering
perspective,
we'll define information as
data communicated or received
that resolves uncertainty
about a particular fact
or circumstance.
In other words, after
receiving the data
we'll know more about
that particular fact
or circumstance.
The greater the uncertainty
resolved by the data,
the more information
the data has conveyed.
LET'S LOOK AT AN
EXAMPLE: a card has
been chosen at random
from a normal deck of 52
playing cards.
Without any data
about the chosen card,
there are 52 possibilities
for the type of the card.
Now suppose you receive one of
the following pieces of data
about the choice.
A. You learn the suit
of the card is "heart".
This narrows the choice
to down one of 13 cards.
B. You learn instead the card
is NOT the Ace of Spades.
This still leaves 51
cards that it might be.
C. You learn instead that
the card is a face card, that
is, a Jack, Queen or King.
So the choice is
one of 12 cards.
D. You learn instead that the
card is the "suicide king."
Our little blue friend is
showing us that this is
actually a particular card – the
King of Hearts where the king
is sticking the sword
through his head!
No uncertainty here, we know
exactly what the choice was.
Which of the possible
pieces of data
conveys the most information?
In other words, which data
resolves the most uncertainty
about the chosen card?
Similarly, which data
conveys the least
amount of information?
Before we talk about
the mathematics
behind the correct answers
to these questions,
vote for your answers
in the following poll.